foreign
-based action game players suit up as
EXO fighters who work for the IBS
Corporation
use a variety of unique EXO suits and
rigs to fit your play style and work
with teammates to combat hordes of
dinosaurs in Dino Survival let's take a
look at the latest trailer we have some
surprises in store so be sure to watch
to the end
in every wool game Ace really is getting
pulled back three years into the past
back to 2040 right before the
stradivator fails
huh you're a time traveler
this is no random outbreak Leviathan is
intentionally summoning them as cannon
fodder for the war game
but why why repeat the same day over and
over
since when exactly did you say your
sister passed
three years ago
one of the first outbreaks
never found out more than that
she's alive
on the island
in the past
[Music]
James you want to try talking to parents
at you
another one
hmm
still handsome
oh
stop
another EXO fighter recruit right
welcome to ibius
what did you think we had a lot of new
info including the release date let's go
over it in detail
EXO Primal Launches on July 14th
before that we'll be holding an open
beta test
in addition to the eight EXO suits we've
previously introduced the two new suits
in today's trailer will also be playable
in the open beta test
experience the power of each exosuit for
yourself as your team faces off against
a wall of dinosaurs in Dino survival the
game's main mode
participants in the open beta test who
fill out a survey will also receive an
IBS metal charm that can be used in the
full game
please visit the official site for beta
test timing content and bonus item info
now I'd like to introduce the survival
pass reward system
as players acquire experience points in
the survival pass their survival pass
level goes up and they earn rewards
separate from player and suit levels
the survival pass includes a free tier
and a paid premium tier
purchasing the premium tier unlocks
access to special rewards including 19
Exo Suit skins and 10 weapon skins
here are some of the rewards
the deluxe edition includes the survival
pass season 1 Premium tier as an added
limited time bonus
EXO Primal launches July 14 2023.
pre-order bonuses are also available
please see the official site for details
on bonus items and the game
the latest EXO Primal news can be found
on the official website and social media
we'll have more for you soon
look forward to seeing you in the open
beta test